rise and shine get up and seize the day
you can do anything under the Sun when
the Sun powers everything your phone
your home and all that's in between this
is life on the golden grid but is it the
Utopia we thought it would be this is
what if and here's what would happen if
all houses were covered with solar
panels in 2018 the state of California
passed a law requiring all new houses to
be built with solar panels after 2020
now you might think this sounds both
extreme and unfair considering it will
raise home prices by as much as 12,000
dollars but it's a lot more sensible
than you think for one families will
actually be making money off their new
homes by saving roughly 19 thousand
dollars over 30 years and in the
meantime California will be generating
74% of its electricity from the Sun
sadly not every place in the world is
like sunny California if we tried to
follow their example
would we be setting ourselves up to fail
actually on the world stage
California's Solar Initiative is hardly
oppressive in Australia for example
roughly 15% of homes are already
equipped with solar panels and in
Belgium it's about 7% of homes but in
the u.s. only 0.5% of homes currently
have solar panels on them of course it
could be a lot more like a lot more
there are just over 8 billion square
meters of suitable roof space in the US
that with solar panels could produce
1400 terawatt-hours of electricity each
year that's 40 percent of the current
energy production in the US
of course we'd have to work out a few
things first it's one thing to require
all homes to have solar panels but to
ensure everyone gets reliable power when
they need it is not so easy for example
some countries don't get as much Sun as
others do or they simply have fewer
people or they have lower energy needs
making it unfeasible for them to rely
only on solar power think of it this way
we said earlier that if every home in
California was equipped with solar
panels the state could generate about
three-quarters of its energy from solar
power but following the same initiative
a state like Wyoming for example would
only be able to get about fourteen
percent of its energy from solar power
so the success of this kind of program
really depends on managing people's
expectations based on the energy needs
of a given region the amount of sunlight
that a region receives and the
population density within its borders
places that are unable to go full on
solar would be encouraged to rely on
other renewables suitable for their
climates the jump in global demand for
solar panels would create millions of
new jobs and businesses to build all
these new solar panels
we'd have to up our silicon and silver
extraction which would be great news for
China since they're the world's leading
silicon producer and the world's second
biggest silver producer we would need
engineers to come up with effective ways
to prevent power surges also known as
solar spills they occur when too much
energy is generated during off-peak
hours like during the day when sunlight
is greatest and demand is lowest this
overwhelms the grid and can trigger
blackouts or frequency issues the
challenge for our engineers then is to
come up with ways to divert and store
the excess energy that's produced and
then recall it when it's needed solar
batteries are a possible solution
although it's a very expensive one but
with any luck the high demand would
reduce the costs associated with going
solar
in any event after installation people
would break even on their solar
technology within five to ten years
would then save significantly on future
utility bills while also saving the
future itself so if this is what you see
today what might you see tomorrow make
hay while the Sun shines
show a friend the future that we could
have and for more bright ideas keep
watching what if
[Music]